kids do the funniest things especially
when they are trying to beat the system
these 20 genius kid hacks will have you
cracking up make sure you watch this
video to the end to see a clever little
guy who figured out how to play outside
while following orders to stay inside if
you like funny cute moments as much as
we do be sure to subscribe and give this
video a big thumbs up and now join us
for 20 genius kids who beat the system
part two dads gasp when it comes to
matter this little scientists sure knows
his stuff he proudly demonstrates it in
this homework drawing which illustrates
solids liquids and gases he's not wrong
but dad might be motivated to change his
diet after seeing this homework
assignment as a matter of fact the whole
family may have to rethink Taco Tuesday
we love it that he put his mom in the
drawing saying ugh we're sure this
clever sketch artist learned a huge
lesson about matter after this
assignment as in some things are a
matter of privacy we hope his dad wasn't
too embarrassed to notice his son's
exceptional drawing skills
this kid has certainly got a future as
an artist or as a comedian keep your eye
on the ball okay can we talk about how
adorable this little guy is he really
wanted to make sure he followed
directions to a tee so when his dad said
keep your eye on the ball that's exactly
what he did as adults we don't realize
how strange some of our sayings are and
so we have to try to explain what they
mean to a child
this future Little League all-star was
just doing when he was told and his
dad's reaction is priceless
that's all right little Slugger you
definitely made your dad smile maybe one
day you'll be major-league until then
keep your eye on the ball roses are red
tests are hard this clever mathematician
found a handy shortcut on our math test
it's a no-brainer really Tony buys one
dozen roses half of them are red how
many of the roses are not red her answer
half if this were a test on choosing the
obvious answer this student would get an
a-plus
however something tells us that wasn't
the answer the teacher was looking for
we pictured this kid confidently leaning
back in her chair wearing sunglasses and
relaxing while her classmates struggled
to finish the test she technically got
the answer right so what's the problem
who's ready for lunch we think we have
the next Ferris Bueller on our hand
toast to the new year this genius
three-year-old started a new family
tradition it began innocently enough
she asked her parents why New Year's Eve
is special they explained it's because
you get to toast to the new year so it's
only natural that a few hours later she
asked the obvious question are we going
to make toast now that may be the best
idea of the entire year who wouldn't
want to celebrate with toast and jelly
we can see why her parents let that be
the start of a new family tradition and
what a great way to include this little
angel on the New Year celebration she
may even carry on this New Year's Day
tradition with her own children eat half
of your grapes someone get this kid an
award she should get a trophy for the
most literal rule-follower ever when
you're a kid
snacks are serious business the less you
have the more you want them the more you
have the less likely you are to eat them
this kid insisted that her mom gave her
too many grapes so her mom told her to
just eat half of them and that's what
she did she ate half of every single
grape we have just one question who is
going to eat the other half or should we
just say halfs she technically did what
her mom asked her to do so her mom can't
possibly have sour grapes about this
right feed the cat it is important to
teach a child the values of being a
responsible pet owner
right that's what these parents thought
when they told their toddler to feed the
cat it would have worked out great if
the cat had opposable thumbs the cat is
looking at his bowl as if to say are you
kidding me clearly the toddler thought
this was a pretty genius idea it's
obvious that he wants the cat to have
the same healthy foods his mom feeds him
so we think it's an adorable show of
love and affection for his feline
companion to give him the gift of a full
unpeeled orange after that maybe he can
teach the captain knit a sweater too
nice to play video games inside as kids
we've all heard our parents yell at us
to go outside and play but now with all
the new video games out there kids need
a constant reminder that there's a whole
world out there that's not attached to a
screen but when this little gamers mom
told her son that it's too nice to play
video games inside this is not what she
had in mind he is technically honoring
her wishes right and he can get to the
next level on his video game win win
though he's not getting much exercise it
did take some effort to lug the table
and chair out there
pretty clever little dude way to game
the system the thinker
at the modern art museum this art
connoisseur was told by his mother to
really think about the works of art he
sees and ask himself what there's
to say mom posted this saying she thinks
she has a wiseguy on her hands there is
no doubt that he took this assignment
quite literally if he had to write a
paper on this piece he would probably
say something like it's a watered down
version of classic Roman fountains very
mainstream and Trites left me thirsting
for something more this mom has
definitely got a jokester on her hands
sure hope she knows how to go with the
flow draw hands on the clocks kids are
living in the digital age so it's not
uncommon for a young mind to have a hard
time grasping the concept of analog
clocks for teachers this means the
struggle is real they have to show
students a clock that doesn't just tell
you the time with digital numbers the
teacher also has to show that clocks can
have faces and even hands it probably
sounded really weird to this kid when
the teacher gave the instructions to
draw hands on clocks why would a clock
need hands when all it does is tell time
this bright student did follow the
teacher's request not one of those
clocks can tell time but they've got
jazz hands down pretty solid making the
computer faster this four-year-olds dad
told his son he was fixing the computer
so it would run faster then the future
tech genius thought of a solution and
thought of it quick after a little while
the young technician proudly told his
dad he had solved the problem and fixed
the computer to make it faster later his
dad found Sonic the Hedgehog inside the
computer tower among the wires and
boards we all know how fast Sonic is
it's pretty logical that he could
increase the speed inside any piece of
equipment he can fit in is this a future
Geek Squad employee or a prankster at
his finest the computer may or may not
run faster after this edition but it
certainly is cuter show you're thinking
to be fair some test questions can be
worded in weird ways this is one of
those times it's as if we are witnessing
the birth of test anxiety in a math test
problem in which Bobby has four dimes
and Amy has 30 pennies the student is
asked which child has more money the
student has the right answer he chose
Bobby but then the test has a rather
strange request it instructs the student
to show you're thinking so the student
drew a picture of himself thinking of
the right answer it even says Bobby in
his thought bubble that answer is right
on the money in our books
bedtime story adventure this little
man's grandpa told them to get ready for
a bedtime story adventure without
hesitating for a second this young
explorer went and grabbed his warm
and a flashlight this might be one of
the cutest things we've ever seen
he's snuggled up to Grandpa and ready
for anything this book can dish out you
never know when you might need to hang
glide over the wilderness explore a dark
Icelandic volcano or discover new Arctic
lands whatever adventure these to dive
into they will definitely be prepared we
just hope his grandpa packed a couple of
sandwiches in case they get hungry on
their great bedtime story journey use
your chopsticks when exploring new
culinary experiences it's important to
immerse oneself in the culture at least
that's what this mom was thinking when
she told her son to use his chopsticks
at a Japanese restaurant now it takes a
certain level of skill to pick up food
with chopsticks but this is next-level
right here the boy wasn't sure how to
eat soup with chopsticks so he used them
to pick up the soup spoon and
masterfully fed himself with his new
invention the chopsticks spoon get this
kid in touch with mr. Miyagi he is
moments away from being able to catch a
fly with those chopsticks well done
Daniel sighs put a jar of water in the
dog's bowl ah sure what better way to
teach a young person about
responsibility but some chores need a
little explaining for example when this
boy's mom asked him to put a jar of
water in the dog's bowl she should have
added the instruction to actually pour
the water from the jar into the bowl is
it this kids fault that he did exactly
what he was told or was he just trying
to get out of an extra step before his
favorite cartoon started either way we
hoped that dog has a long tongue well
played young one we're sure your parents
will think more carefully the next time
they ask you to give the dog some water
just hanging around this little
fashionista looks like she loves trying
on new clothes so imagine her
disappointment when her mother told her
she couldn't take the clothes off the
hangers and try them on when she saw a
must-have item on the racks she thought
quickly her mom came around the corner
to find her like this
now technically she didn't break the
rules she just found the best of both
worlds the jacket is still on the hanger
but now it's just inhabited by a curious
little shopper that's definitely her
color do you think this little trick
helps convince her mom to add to what
must be an extensive wardrobe collection
put the pizza costume back where it goes
many parents know the struggle of taking
kids to the store it starts out as a
quick shopping trip to pick up the
essentials and you end up with a bunch
of unnecessary extras in your cart like
for example a pizza costume who wouldn't
want to dress up as a slice of pizza
that's what this clever
argued right before his parents told him
to put the pizza costume back where it
goes in all the excitement of fighting
such a treasure he may have lost track
of what Isle de costume came from so he
found the next illogical place he's not
wrong is he I don't want to see the
cooler in your room again
what cooler it's just a masterfully
constructed cushion for it the perfect
size for which to hide up forbidden
cooler this little camper obeyed his
parent when he said he didn't want to
see the cooler in his room again well if
it's hidden inside a cushion fortress no
parent has to see it they're right his
dad said he wasn't even mad this is one
way to protect your parents from
witnessing the bending of a few rules it
does beg the question what's in the
cooler why would the kid rather disguise
it than return it to the garage exactly
how many Capri Suns is he hiding in
there
draw a plant cell this is probably far
from what the teacher expected when she
asked her student to draw a plant cell
the classroom was learning about phyto
cells and plants but this kid took a
whole different meaning from the
assignment he even went so far as to
write no windows and iron bars just in
case drawing of the pouting flower in
the jail cell didn't come across our
question is what is this flowers crime
extortion of bees pollinating without a
permit in any case we think this is a
pretty clever answer maybe his parents
should stop letting him watch crime
shows before he starts booking
dandelions too just gotta finish these
mixes kids love to help their parents at
work this two-year-old is no exception
when her dad told her he just had to
finish some mixes on the computer she
immediately went to her kitchen and
grabbed the mixing bowl and a whisk she
put it on his desk confident that this
would speed up the process for him after
all a person needs the proper tools when
trying to finish up a mix we're gonna go
out on a limb and say that's probably
not the kind of mixing her dad was doing
but you gotta love that sincere effort
she can hold her head up high knowing
she was the one responsible for helping
daddy finish those mixes on time don't
set one foot outside when you tell your
child not to set one foot outside and he
finds a way to play outside without
officially breaking the rules you've got
a pause and applaud his cleverness it's
clear that this kid wanted to go outside
but still wanted to follow his mom's
orders so he came up with this genius
solution not a bad idea
his mom only said not to step his feet
outside but she didn't mention the rest
of his body
this mom had better get ready
she may have a slide ago she ate Iran
her hands you can tell he is just
sitting there thinking of ways to get
around all the rest of the rules - and
there you have it for 20 kids who beat
the system part - if you haven't seen
kids who beat the system part one be
sure to check it out thanks for watching
[Music]